>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Talia Guzman-Gonzales: On behalf
of the Hispanic division I would
like to welcome everyone
to this beautiful room.
It's quite a treat for me to be here
so I hope you appreciate
that as well.
This is the Rosenwald
Room of the Rare Book
and Special Collection Division
who also helped us collect this
wonderful display that we're going
to be talking about after the talk.
As you know this year we celebrate
the 400 anniversary of the death
of Miguel de Cervantes Saavedra,
the author of "Don Quixote",
first novel reaching the modern
world and published in 1605
and today you get to see one of
those 1605 editions so it's--
>> Oh my.
>> Talia Guzman-Gonzales:
pretty exciting.
The Library of Congress has an
unparalleled collection of editions
of "Don Quixote" and other
miscellany including two definitive
editions, one pirated in Portugal
and another published
by the author in Spain.
The library also has
the translations--
all the translations
to "Don Quixote" including a
beautifully illustrated edition
in [inaudible] that we
couldn't bring today
but we have another event
on "Don Quixote" in December
and we'll have that then.
Researchers who would like to learn
more about our collection can start
by [inaudible] book where we,
it's a collection of the books of,
by Miguel de Cervantes in
the Library of Congress.
So today we have the pleasure
of welcoming Professor Hernan
Sanchez Martinez de Pinillos
from the Department
of Spanish Portuguese
at the University of Maryland.
>> Whoo!
>> Talia Guzman-Gonzales: [Laughs]
Professor de Pinillos holds a
Bachelors and a PhD in
Medieval Literature with Honors
for the Best Dissertation
in Spanish Philology
at the Universidad Complutense.
He has a Masters in Philosophy and a
PhD in Spanish Golden Age Literature
from Columbia University
in New York.
He is corresponding member for the
Spanish Royal Academy of History
since 2012 and a Member Collaborator
of Cilengua Centro Internactional de
Investigacion de la Lengua Espanola.
He has published a
scholarly edition and study
of a 15th century manuscript
and numerous articles
in prestigious journals
on major works of Spanish
and Latin American
Literature including Cervantes,
Lope de Vega and Quevedo.
Currently he's working, or he's
reviewing a publication of the books
"La poesia del pensamiento
Quevedo y la tradicion occidental",
and "Cervantes and Edgar
Allen Poe in Counterpoint".
After Professor de Pinillos' talk
we're going to have my colleague
from the Hispanic Division Juan
Manuel Perez is going to be talking
about some of the rare
editions that we have here
at the Library of Congress.
So I hope you'll stay
for that as well.
So welcome, Hernan.
>> Hernan Pinillos: Thank you very
much all of you for being here today
on a rainy Friday afternoon.
Thank you very much Dr. Georgette
Dorn from the Hispanic Division
and thank you Talia and thank you
[talking in foreign language] from--
[ Inaudible ]
>> Hernan Pinillos: That was?
Okay. Yeah I was thanking Dr.
Georgette Dorn for the opportunity
to commemorate Cervantes'
anniversary--
the anniversary of his
death and Talia and the head
of the Hispanic department also for
well, yeah, contributing to this,
the possibility of this event.
I'm going to be talking
a bit about the invention
of the character Don Quixote, how
the novel presents this character
and the construction of the
novel and then the projection
of "Don Quixote" throughout
the ages in different context.
In the opening chapter of Cervantes'
"Don Quixote" we meet a middle aged
small town bachelor whose life is
defined by its monotony
and invisibility.
He lives with his young
niece and with a housekeeper.
He has but two friends.
His name is Alonso
Quijano or Quijada.
Alonso has no productive activity
to occupy his fertile imagination.
As we are informed
of the dull details
of a poor hidalgo's
everyday life we learn
that his only distinctive feature
is that he devotes all his time,
day and night, to the task of
absorbing books of chivalry
to the point of obsession.
Ignoring their [inaudible]
distinction between history
and poetry, Alonso Quijano loses
himself in books of fiction he deems
to be histories of facts.
In the madness of reading
fictional literature as history,
Alonso Quijano begins to imagine
the script for his own life.
And at this point something
remarkable occurs.
Quijano begins moving out of himself
as he formulates a new life project
in the form of a real
character of his own invention.
We as readers are present as
Alonso Quijano reinvents himself.
The character invented by the
author is presented to the reader
in his intimate process of
transformation and self invention.
A main character invented
by Cervantes,
Alonso Quijano recreates himself
as the knight Don Quixote.
By naming himself-- it takes a week
to think of his name, Don Quixote--
Alonso Quijano literally wills
himself into a new existence.
In a sort of reproduction
of the baptismal sacrament,
an outer baptism of sorts as
some critics have termed it,
Alonso Quijano's madness and
conversion are here inseparable.
Madness is conversion and
conversion is madness.
We can recall all the famous
religious conversions of the past.
St. Paul, St. Augustine,
St. Francis.
But even more relevant are
Ignatius of Loyola and Santa Teresa
who are great readers
of chivalry novels.
Ignatius of Loyola read romances
of chivalry while convalescing
from a wound, and the
religious order he created,
the Jesuit Society, was to be
a sort of spiritual knighthood.
So you see the parallels.
The stated cause of Alonso
Quijano's conversion is reading,
but the underlining causes have been
described differently by critics.
Midlife crisis.
Boredom. Love.
Fear of old age.
The will to leave behind an
empty and meaningless existence.
And thus the knight Don
Quijano, the hero of a tale
of chivalry is being born.
From now on his life will be an
imitation of art and an attempt
in transforming life into art.
Ortega said, whose philosophical
system was born as a commentary
of "Don Quixote" in 1914 in the book
"Meditaciones del Quijote" wrote
in 1935 in [inaudible] that whether
he be original or a plagiarist man--
man or and women-- or women, are
the novelist of him or herself.
Women and men are continually
rewriting themselves
after becoming dissatisfied
with older versions,
with their older versions and then
revising their previous selves
into someone new.
Bored of being the
invisible man Alonso Quijano,
the ostracized non-entity
Alonso Quijano the great reader
of novels will die to be reborn
as the author of his own story,
the novelist of his own existence.
A life titled "The Ingenious Hidalgo
Don Quixote de la Mancha" [talking
in foreign language], a title that
is both absurd and subversive.
The adjective ingenious doesn't
usually qualify the noun hidalgo,
a social category of lower nobility
whose distinctive mark like that
of all nobility would be courage.
In the medical treatises of
the times, men of high wit,
[talking in foreign
language] were described
as having a precarious
psychological balance.
[Talking in foreign language]
was typically accompanied
by some sort of mania, no?
So this is a strange
juxtaposition, no?
[Talking in foreign
language] After [talking
in foreign language] comes the
honorific title Don [talking
in foreign language] .
Together Hidalgo and Don
represent a contradiction.
This is a socially subversive
equalitarian absurdity.
Usurping the title Don, reserved
for the upper classes of the,
the real upper ranks
of the nobility,
our hero's promoting himself
from the class of the hidalgo,
the lowest rung of the
nobility to that of a caballero.
Those who could introduce their
first name with the title, Don.
So, [talking in foreign
language] is completely an absurd
and also subversive title.
Here the Don is related to caballero
and caballero has a double meaning
in the mind of Don Quixote.
Well in the mind of Don Quixote
it represents a night in--
a night errant, a knight
in shining armor.
But caballero is also a social
rank, so here you see the conflict,
the misadjustment between
literature and life
that will characterize
all of "Don Quixote".
The social meaning of Don pulls
the character back into the reality
of contemporary Spain in 1600
even as he attempts to escape
that reality into literature,
escaping into literature.
The antithesis between
the fake Don title
and the hidalgo condition
is followed
by the augmentative Quixote.
Derived from the pejorative
suffix ote modeled
after the last name Quijano.
Don should antecede the first name,
as in Don Alonso, or
in Don [inaudible].
So we have here another absurdity.
The name Quixote is derived
from the last name Quijano
but in Spanish surnames
derived from first names.
Sanchez originally
meant son of Sancho.
Gonzales, son of Gonzalo and so on.
And the name Don Quixote
the normal linguistic
and historical process
has been inverted.
The first name is derived
from the family name.
So the aberration of the title Don
with a surname, the family Quijano
or Quijada affix in the
manner corresponding
to a given name is the
onomastic expression
of the protagonist
subversive madness.
The name Quixote is
most probably derived
from the [inaudible] word [talking
in foreign language] a piece
of armor that covered the thigh.
Don Quixote is modeled after Sir
Lancelot, King Arthur's champion
with whom Don Quixote
will prove to be obsessed.
But instead of an offensive
armor like the lance eluded
to in the name Lancelot, Quixote
refers to a defensive armor
that covers the area
around the genitals
which has inspired quite a few
several psychoanalytic readings, no?
So then we have "El Ingenioso
hidalgo don Quixote de la Mancha",
no?
De la Mancha in contrast with
the exotic beautiful landscapes
of idealized romance novels, Don
Quixote hails from the parched,
uninteresting, dry plains of
la Mancha and central Spain.
In imitation of Amadis who
hails from Gaula, Wales,
Don Quixote incorporates
his homeland de la Mancha
into his name as well.
The associations that de la Mancha
convey are opposed to the enchanted
and exotic faraway lands of
the original chivalry knights.
Furthermore, la Mancha
has a double meaning.
It refers to this dry
region south of Madrid,
but mancha also means stain which
could imply of converse origin,
not of pure blood, in
another possible jab
at the established
order's ideological system.
Well if Cervantes creates
Dulcinea who has--
I'm sorry, if Cervantes
creates Alonso Quijano
who has created Don Quixote,
Don Quixote in turn
invents the fair Dulcinea
from a [inaudible] according
to Sanchos' description,
peasant girl from neighboring
[talking in foreign language] .
The romantic and existentialist
versions of Dulcinea has become,
they have become popularized
as explained
by the Spanish philosopher
Miguel de Unamuno.
The causes of this
love affair as follows.
Idleness and an unfortunate
love affair led him
to reading books of knight errantry.
And after several pages of extolling
Dulcinea's [inaudible] of glory,
Unamuno addresses "Don Quixote"
as follow: And now my Don Quixote,
take me somewhere where we can
be alone together for I want
to have a heart to heart talk and
speak to you as many men do not care
to speak even to themselves.
Was it really your love of glory
that led you to invest [inaudible]
of whom for a while you were
enamored with the image of Dulcinea?
Or was it your unhappy love for
the commonly young peasant girl,
the love which she never heard of
nor paid any heed to which turned
into love of immortality?
So Don Quixote's love quest for
Dulcinea will be, as you know,
one of the main drives of the novel.
And so how is Don Quixote born?
How is the character set
out on the roads of Spain?
Well he is born free from baggage.
A new man in a 50 year olds body
who in his madness believes
he is a knight errant.
A new identity is anachronistic
both from a historical
and from a biographical
point of view.
As his niece will point
out in the beginning
of part two, Don Quixote
is obsolete.
His materials conditions,
age, physique,
social and economic
circumstances make him unsuitable
for his intended life project.
Very little is known of the
protagonist's 50 first years.
We do know that he, that as he
approached his late 40's he turned
to reading novels of chivalry.
But Cervantes offers us
nothing, or next to nothing.
Old book without a
past we know nothing
about his parents nor
his birthplace.
Why is this?
What is Cervantes' purpose?
Alonso Quijano has been a non-entity
for almost 50 years as we said,
and the [inaudible] regarded--
as the [inaudible] regarding the
protagonist's names underscores.
But this lack of a past
allows the author to create,
to give us a character with
greater freedom of movements.
He evades predestination, present
in the heroic, aristocratic,
idealized romances of chivalry,
and also the determinism
of the anti-heroic picaresque
novels with their materialistic
and pessimistic anthropology
that foreshadows
in many ways social Darwinism.
A symbolic understanding
of Don Quixote's lack
of early life history can be seen as
the expression of all that is new,
the importance of the future instead
of the past, of the possibility
of self creation, self recreation
versus social conformism,
a slap in the face of the
established order once again.
Don Quixote's born as an act
of independence of a new kind
of hero, heterodox and alone.
And so in chapter two the
imposter, the self appointed knight,
Don Quixote de la Mancha will set
out on his adventures
one hot July morning.
Don Quixote breaks away from
his past, from the monotonous
and predicable existence of his
small town of 50 year old life
and he is born to run on the road
less traveled and breaking bad.
Because Don Quixote
will be excommunicating
for attacking a funeral procession.
Don Quixote will become an
outlaw after setting free a group
of [inaudible] dangerous
prisoners in shackles.
But Don Quixote does
have, in spite of this,
a strong ethical and
aesthetic system.
A complex personal creation made
up of the heroic code of romances
of chivalry, of the perfect
courtly lover infused
with biblical ancient
Greek and Christian values.
In his self invention, Don Quixote
will rely on two famous sentences
that will carry him and
Sancho through the novel
to Barcelona and back home.
The first one is, "each person
is the heir of his own actions"
or more literally, "each person
is the child of his own words".
The Spanish for this well known line
is [talking in foreign language].
To a Spanish [inaudible] cannot fail
to invite comparisons with [talking
in foreign language]
literally son of something
and more appropriately
translated as son of somebody.
[Talking in foreign language]
was subsequently shortened
into hidalgo meaning gentleman.
Since hidalgo explained one's status
as deriving from one's ancestors,
the countering assertion that each
one is [talking in foreign language]
that is, each one's worth is a
result of what he does rather
than what forbearers
did or were have reputed
to have done is an expression of
more than idle observation in an age
which antedates the first successful
social revolutions in Europe.
[talking in foreign language]
reflects a manner of valiant people,
not by social status
or popular esteem
but by their true moral worth.
The other sentence that founds Don
Quixote's personal ethical system
is, "I know who I am and who I
could become", said by Don Quixote
to his neighbor Pedro Alonzo in
the fifth chapter of the first part
when his neighbor finds the
knight confused and beaten up
and referring to books of chivalry.
The peasant, baffled by these
words uttered with such conviction,
will manage to escort Don
Quixote back to his village.
[Talking in foreign language]
said in a different context,
trite as it may seem to us, a
logical statement of identity,
I am I, the fundamental
statement of consciousness is
in reality a tremendous achievement.
In Don Quixote's phrase,
it can be read
and has been read alongside
other defining religious, moral,
existential and philosophical
maxims no?
I am who I am, Exodus 3:14.
Pindar's, become whom you are.
Socrates, know thyself.
Polonius, to thine own self be true.
Descartes, you know, I
think therefore I am.
Spanish philosophers
Unamuno and Ortega y Gasset
who both kick-started their own
systems of thought as a meditated
of Cervantes' novel commented
intensely this phrase
in an existentialist context.
Ortega founded his
concept of the heroic
on what he deemed Don
Quixote's courageous will
to resist the pressures
that will lead him
to lead an inauthentic existence.
Hero for Ortega is he
or she who discovers
and affirms her original self
against all social conventions,
obstacles, prejudices,
conventions, or expectations.
What is extraordinary is that
Don Quixote joins from the outset
of the novel the aspiration to
take action to self knowledge.
Other famous characters believe
that an individual
designs his own fortune.
In Shakespeare, Iago
and Hamlet for instance.
But only Don Quixote links self
realization to self knowledge.
The following quote from a
popular best seller self help book,
this quote really captures
the essence
of the romantic existentialist
tradition of Quixote commentary.
The book is "I Will Not Die an
Unlived Life" by Dawna Markova.
Through fear of knowing
who we really are,
we sidestep our own destiny
which leaves us hungry
in a famine for our own making.
We end up living numb,
passionless lives disconnected
from our soul's true purpose.
But when we have the
courage to say--
but when we have the courage to
save our life from the essence
of who we are, we ignite
becoming truly alive.
But Don Quixote is not alone.
In chapter seven he [inaudible]
himself with a squire for he,
for which he chooses a peasant from
his village named Sancho Panza.
Sancho Panza is everything Don
Quixote is not and vice versa.
Everybody, including people
who have never read the book,
know that Don Quixote's tall and
thin, Sancho's short and fat.
The word Panza means
potbelly in Spanish.
Don Quixote is a very
minor aristocrat.
Sancho a commoner.
Don Quixote's a great reader.
In fact this is what
makes him Don Quixote.
Whereas Sancho is an
illiterate peasant.
Sancho becomes, belongs to
the culture of [inaudible].
He opposes the great body of folk
wisdom crystallizing proverbs
to Don Quixote's reliance
on written text.
So there will be a
continuous contrast
between Don Quixote's
expansive literary imagination
and Sancho's common sense.
Don Quixote champions the
personalism of feudalism
with its reciprocal and abstract set
of mutual obligations while Sancho
yearns for a relationship based
on and mediated by money.
But these are not of
course absolute oppositions.
George Orwell in an
article entitled,
"The Art of Donald McGill",
observed that two principles--
noble folly and base wisdom--
exist side by side in
nearly every human being.
If you look into your
own mind, which are you,
Don Quixote or Sancho Panza?
Almost certainly you are both.
There is one part of you that
wishes to be a hero or a saint
but another part of
you is a little man
who sees very clearly the advantages
of staying alive with a whole skin.
He is your unofficial self,
the voice of the belly
protesting against the soul.
It is simply a lie to say
that he is not part of you,
just as is it a lie-- just as it
is a lie to say that Don Quixote,
that Don Quixote's not
a part of you either.
So Don Quixote will be based
on the unending conversations,
exchanges between Sancho
Panza and his master.
In contrast with the Picaresque
novel and its monological world
of survival, isolation,
and loneliness,
in Don Quixote the dialogue allows
both characters to define themself--
themselves, and influence
each other.
A dialogue always assumes
a certain degree
of equality between the speakers.
The opposite of a dialogue
is the sermon,
the harangued official speech.
Europe as you know was divided
into strict social classes
and that class rigidity
made dialogue
across lines extremely difficult.
But Cervantes created a
situation in his novel
that required a constant
crossing of class lines
in the continuous dialogue
between a peasant and an hidalgo.
It would be hard or
perhaps impossible
to find a similar situation in prose
writings in Spain or elsewhere.
It is true that we have
in Spanish place many,
many a place with the
archetypical funny man [inaudible]
who had criticized the
behavior of young nobles.
But this group of plays categorized
as comedias, a genre favored
by local hidalga and
other playwrights.
In these comedias [inaudible]
criticism was on the whole discarded
by the play's upper
class characters.
[Talking in foreign language]
would connect with the audience
who would laugh at him when
he pokes fun at the noble
but incomprehensible
ideals of the upper classes.
Because he could not understand
their motivations nor their values.
So the Spanish plays have been
described as a dialogue of the deaf
in terms of social classes.
In Cervantes' novel it's-- on the
contrary it is a constant exchange
between the authority
figure of Don Quixote
and the illiterate Sancho Panza
who has on his sides facts
and common sense, what
will carry the novel.
Language communicates,
reveals the inner self
of one's character to another.
Never in literature had dialogue
and conversation been shown
as so integral to experience before.
Don Quixote and Sancho
never talk past each other.
They listen carefully and adjust
their answers accordingly.
And their unending
polemic conversations
and winning camaraderie and
true bonding will culminate
in a true friendship expressed in a
letter that Don Quixote will address
to Sancho Panza in the
second part of the novel
that he will sign simply
as "your friend".
We can, from a more abstract point
of view we can see in this portents
of the dialogue, a protest
against dogmatism, against the idea
of a static, unidimensional
world view, you know?
Cervantes' novel is structured
as a dialogue on the road
and an outward journey with
several stays at an inn or a castle
with numerous encounters with
people of all social levels.
But this journey is also a tour
through all the literary regions
of the imagination known in
the early 17th century Spain.
"Don Quixote" simultaneously
incorporates into itself and carries
on a dialogue with all
the forms of fictional
and non-fictional literature
current in that time.
Professions of literature, and that
includes both writers and critics,
consider "Don Quixote" at the
center of the history of the novel.
It includes and sums up
everything that went before it.
[Inaudible] essay in the prologue,
[inaudible] and chivalry novels
in the form of parody, the
pastoral and picaresque novels,
byzantine novels, Italian
humanism, Spanish mysticism,
the perfect tragedy and prose, comic
plays, [inaudible] sonnets, ballads
and burlesque poems, etcetera.
No book owes so much for
existing literature and no book is
so different from that literature
wrote Carroll B. Johnson.
So as Don Quixote the character
breaks away from his past,
as he broke away from
his past and refused
to accept the social role
handed to him by his ancestors
and his environment, Cervantes
the author will break away
from all forms of literary
imagination once he has absorbed
them and proven that he
could write excellently
in all those different
genres and forms.
The second part of
Cervantes can be--
the second part of the novel can
be described as Cervantes' act
of independence from tradition.
After proving like later young
Picasso that he could model
and excel-- he could excel in every
mode known of literary imagination.
But Don Quixote of course
as you know not only sums
what has been written before,
but also projects itself
into the future.
As [inaudible] observed, all the
ideas of western novel are present
in [inaudible] in "Don Quixote".
From "Joseph Andrews" written
in the manner of Cervantes
by Henry Fielding, to Charlotte
Lennox's "The Female Quixote",
from Tabitha Tenney's
"Female Quixoticism"
and most popular novel
written in America prior
to the publication of
"Uncle Tom's Cabin".
From "Moby Dick" and "Madame
Bovary" to Dostoevsky's "The Idiot",
from "The Great Gatsby"
and the novels of Galdos
to "Huckleberry Finn" and Faulkner
and Kathy Acker's "Don Quixote"
which was a dream, novelists had
been exploiting and experimenting
with the possibilities inherent
in what Harry Levin called
the Cervantine principle.
Every novel bears a Quixote within
it like an inner filigree just
as every epic poem contains
"The Iliad", like the fruit,
its core observed Ortega
y Gasset in 1914.
[Inaudible] imagination observed
that "Don Quixote" contains
within itself the whole
potentiality of the genre,
and that the entire history of the
novel could be justifiably thought
as iteration of the
theme of Don Quixote.
The old opposition between
reality and appearance,
between what merely is
and what merely seems.
Here are some of the lessons
created and passed on by Cervantes
to later novels: the
anti-hero as protagonist
and a new understanding of heroism.
The celebration of freedom through
the poetics, authors, narrators,
characters, readers, and the
anthropology of the novel.
The conflict between inner
conscience and the outside world.
The antithesis between
imagination and the pragmatic,
or between poetry and prose.
The inclusion of all social
levels of language and the renewal
of rhetoric through the
omnipresence of spoken language.
The fusion of travel and dialogue
is a commentary both critical
and compassionate on humanity.
The alternation of adventure
and experience, and of humor
and philosophical depth,
the truth of fiction
versus the fictitious
appearance of reality.
The questioning of the
relation between what happened--
the story, and the account of
what happened-- the discourse.
The art of capturing a person's
faith in a single phrase.
The invention of a myth that
springs from a core of a culture,
from the core of a culture.
The novel as a self reflecting
genre through irony, playfulness,
and parody and the
development of meta-fiction.
"Don Quixote" intertwined stories
and different levels of fiction,
literature within literature,
written by numerous
internal authors.
The first author, the second author
and unreliable narrator
named [talking
in foreign language] historian,
the Morisco translators,
the Morisco translator.
But also many of the
characters are writers as well.
The [talking in foreign language]
the lovers and poets [talking
in foreign language] the captain
who chronicles his life as captain
in Algiers, the [inaudible] from
Toledo who writes chivalry novels
and Don Quixote himself as a
character in search of an author
who will write down his deeds.
Cervantes creates a meta-fiction
in which the massive presence
of literature is complemented by a
series of theoretical discussions
on the art of literature.
Arising as a natural consequence
of Don Quixote's strange
literature-based madness.
From the 9th chapter of the first
part, Don Quixote will be the story
of the fictional protagonist
and what happens to them.
And simultaneously a meditation
on the nature and modes
of invention of a literary text.
That is, "Don Quixote" is a novel
about the adventures of Don Quixote
and Sancho and a book about the
adventure of writing "Don Quixote".
In the second part of the novel,
the characters become readers
of the first part and
discuss literature
as though they the invented
characters were as real
as the author and us the readers.
Pirandello and Unamuno-- Pirandello
in "Six Characters in Search
of an Author" and Unamuno
in his novel [inaudible]
"Mist" will take Cervantes'
strategy to the limit
and make the character
more real than the author,
rebel against said author.
Meta-fiction is a narrative
form of metaphysical questioning
which makes us ponder our
own place in the world.
And as [inaudible] observed
in the, in his essay [talking
in foreign language] it unsettles
the reader's own reality principle.
According to [inaudible]
Don Quixote's legacy is
that the novelist teachers
the reader how
to comprehend the world
as a question.
And last but not least,
Cervantes gave us a literary form
where a character undergoes
deep inner development
and transformation.
From conversion and
madness to lucidity
and reckless spiritual youth
to wise disillusionment.
Cervantes promises in the
prologue of the second part
to give the reader "Don
Quixote" character [talking
in foreign language] expanded
versus the arrested development
of the wooden characters
in bad novels such as
"The False Quixote" written
by Cervantes' mysterious enemy
Alonso Fernandez Avellaneda.
The Quixote of part two is a changed
man and the novel can be read
as the growth of a poetic mind,
a poetic mind that
develops a new inwardness
and melancholy possessed
by self doubt.
Don Quixote gives up most of the
aggression and [inaudible] violence
that mark his attempt to revive
[inaudible] chivalry in part one
and adopts a new moderation, peace
ability and humanity according
to David Quint in "Cervantes's
Novel of Modern Times".
And Sancho who grows in
importance as the novel develops,
evolves as well, from a peasant
with not much in the way of brains
to the wise governorship
of [inaudible].
Cervantes' novel can in fact
be read as Sancho's [talking
in foreign language] Sancho's
formation and education.
Perhaps it is this
quality of Cervantes' novel
that [inaudible] Dostoevsky
to conclude that
"Don Quixote" condenses the deepest
meaning of the human experience.
Here is the famous passage
from "A Writer's Diary":
"There is nothing deeper and
more powerful in the whole world
than this piece of fiction.
It is the final and greatest
expression of human thought,
the most bitter irony that a
human is capable of expressing.
And if the world came to an and
people were asked somewhere,
well did you understand
anything from life on earth
and draw any conclusion from it?
A person could silently
hand over 'Don Quixote'.
Here is my conclusion about life".
Due perhaps to the symbolic
power behind the mythic
and easily visualized Quixoticism,
Cervantes's invention has inspired
an extraordinary number of readings,
interpretations, adaptations, and
re-fashionings in almost every genre
and medium from sculpture
and painting
to opera and animated cartoon.
Modern philosophy and politics
also cannot be understood
without the mark of "Don Quixote".
In Anglo-America this influence
can be recognized at the level
of mentalities in the process of
Don Quixote's self invention based
on his personal notion of
freedom and responsibility.
This could be linked to the
archetype of the self made man
and Don Quixote's famous phrase
in chapter 66 of second half,
"Every man is the architect
of his own destiny" encapsulates
this attitude, this stance.
He says, "Every man is the
architect of his own destiny"
when Sancho Panza is
looking for excuses
after his questionable defeat
against the Knight of the White Moon
when he accepts full responsibility.
Thomas Jefferson considered "Don
Quixote" the best work in its genre
and had his daughters study Spanish
with a copy of "Don Quixote".
In Jefferson's political rhetoric
of freedom and potential equality
and the "all men are created
equal" sentence contained
in the second paragraph of
the United States Declaration
of Independence we can recognize Don
Quixote's personal moral philosophy
[talking in foreign language] .
Abraham Lincoln's second
inaugural address, March 4th,
1865 famous motto "with malice
towards none, with charity for all",
echoes the ending words of
Don Quixote's self portrait
in chapter 32 of the
second part of the novel.
After having listened to
the disparaging condemnation
of his life's purpose and ideals
by the judgmental house chaplain
in the duke's palace, Don Quixote
concludes his self defense speech
with the following words:
[talking in foreign language]
In Tobias Smollett's
1755 translation,
"my intention I always
direct to a worthy aim;
namely to do good unto all
men and harm to no creature".
Dr. Martin Luther King's
Quixotic 1963
"I Have a Dream" speech
can be read as modeled
after the romantic interpretation
of Don Quixote's declared mission
in his famous golden age speech,
to bring back the golden age utopia
on Earth, to go forth and change
the world and to build a society
that is nobler, kinder, and just.
Chapter 11 of "Don
Quixote", first part.
Recently, American
filmmaker Martin Scorsese
in his autobiography writes,
"I read 'Don Quixote' just before
starting 'Gangs of New York'
and discovered that everything
you might want to do with style,
Cervantes did first; time
shifts, answering his critics
of the first volume in the
second, all the new wave tricks.
It's both terribly
funny and maddening
because by the end you don't
really know where the point
of view is coming from,
who Don Quixote is,
or if he really believed
in what he was doing.
And the relationship with
Sancho Panza is great,
but over the years I
was against reading it
because it had become a cliche.
The man charging at the
windmills and all that.
The one film version I did see
was Grigori Kozintsev's made
in Russia 1957 which
I thought was good,
but I haven't seen [inaudible] film,
and 'Man of La Mancha'
really isn't for me.
Anyway, I just found out that
Cervantes did it all even before
Joyce and Melville.
In conclusion I would like
to pay the brief homage
to Bob Dylan alongside Cervantes,
the recent Nobel Prize winner."
Well let us compare the
episode of Don Quixote's dream
within a dream story in Montesinos
Cave in the second part chapter 23
with Bob Dylan's iconic 1965 song
"Desolation Road", the closing track
of Dylan's studio album
"Highway 61 Revisited".
Dreams have fascinated people for
centuries and are present in some
of the world's oldest texts.
For example, Pharaoh's
dream interpreted
by Joseph in the Old Testament.
Latin literature has Scipio's dream
complete with a trip to the moon
and a vision of the
future of the Roman Empire.
Yet the difference
between these dreams
and Don Quixote's dreams
is essential.
Most dreams from ancient literary
text are either revelations
about the future or premonitions
of future disasters
or coming successes.
Not so with Don Quixote's dream.
In it our hero is deeply
troubled by his role in history
and especially worried
about his relationship
with Dulcinea, or to Dulcinea.
Don Quixote wakes up after
falling asleep when he sits
down in the cave, and so
he awakens within a dream.
Montesinos, the legendary
figure of Carolingian ballads,
that is Spanish ballads inspired
by the French epic poem [talking
in foreign language] greets the
knight of the sad countenance.
And he says, "it's been a long time
valiant Don Quixote de la Mancha,
that we who live in these
lonely places have been awaiting
for your visit.
Come with me illustrious sir, and I
shall show you the marvels concealed
in this transparent castle.
Translation, John Rutherford.
Don Quixote continues his account
to Sancho Panza and his guide
and to the guide who
led him to the cave.
Says Don Quixote, "The
venerable Montesinos took me
into the crystal palace where
there was a marble tomb upon
which I saw a knight who was lying
not one of bronze, marble, or jasper
but made of real flesh
and real blood".
Don Quixote-- Montesinos explains
to Don Quixote that it is--
that this is his friend Durandarte,
the flower and mirror of the brave
and enamored knights of
his time, kept there,
enchanted like many other men
and women are also kept here
by Merlin the French sorcerer.
Durandarte had breathed his
last breath in Montesinos' arms
after requesting that his
heart be cut out and taken
to his beloved Belerma as a
famous ballad sung in his tomb.
Oh my cousin Montesinos,
listen to my last request.
When I'm lying dead before you and
my soul's flown from my breast,
take a poniard or a dagger,
cut my heart from out of me,
carry it to fair Belerma,
to wherever she may be.
Although more than 500
years have now passed,
none of us has really
died says Montesinos.
Don Quixote then recounts a scene
where there was a great
weeping and wailing.
I turned my head and through
the crystal walls I saw
in another room procession
of two files
of lonely damsels, all mourning.
All the people in the processions
were the servants of Belerma
and Durandarte enchanted together
with their master and mistress.
Montesinos informs that the pallor
and the rings under the eyes
of Belerma are not caused by that
problem women have every month
because it has been
months and even years
since it last came
knocking on her door.
We inhabit an underworld where the
characters are grotesque distortions
of their previous heroic selves.
Leading the strange
absurd life trapped
in another dimension
of space and time.
One hour has passed
according to Sancho,
and three days according
to Don Quixote.
But as Sancho Panza says, maybe
what seems to us like an hour seems
like three days down there.
Cervantes' degraded
vision of the past reveals
to us how the subconscious mind
of Don Quixote is much less sure
of his role in the world
and of the moral qualities
of the woman he loves.
The mythical times of heroes
and legends has been infiltrated
and slowly eroded by prosaic
details, aging and decay.
And nothing similar can be
found in renaissance literature.
Placing myth in a prosaic setting,
subjecting the idealized creatures
of legend to real time is a
mode of questioning and dealing
with the past passed down from
Cervantes to Kafka's "Metamorphosis"
and Joyce's "Ulysses"
and relived by Bob Dylan
to revolutionize the
American song tradition.
In "Desolation Row" in its surreal
lyrics, Dylan weaved characters
from history, fiction, the
Bible, and of his own invention
into a series of vignettes that
suggest entropy and urban chaos.
For Andy Gill, the second is
"an 11 minute epic of entropy,
which takes the form of a
Fellini-esque parade of grotesques
and oddities featuring a huge
cast of iconic characters,
some historical, some Biblical,
some literary, and some who fit
in none of the above categories.
And some as Romeo,
Cinderella, and Ophelia taken
from the idealized literature that
purveys Don Quixote's imagination.
In Cervantes' cave of Montesinos, an
uncanny purgatory of broken myths--
Cervantes' cave of Montesinos
uncanny purgatory of broken myths,
the heroes of French epic and
Arthurian legends have become,
alongside Don Quixote's beloved
Dulcinea, enchanted figures
of desolation, eroded by centuries
of prose, quiet in their tombs,
or passing by in a whaling
procession of unending sorrow.
In Dylan's "Desolation Row", Cane
and Abel, Robin Hood, Casanova,
the Hunchback of Notre Dame, the
Phantom of the Opera, Cinderella,
Romeo and Ophelia unite with
Belerma and Durandarte, Montesinos
and Dulcinea, lost souls in a poetic
limbo awaiting for [inaudible]
for the messiah knight or
the American [inaudible]
who would redeem them from
the horrors of history,
from the horrors of time.
Now, sit [inaudible].
[ Applause ]
>> Talia Guzman-Gonzales: Would
you take some questions from them?
>> Hernan Pinillos: Yeah, sure.
>> I have a question.
It's not every day that we get to
meet an expert on "Don Quixote"
and I just have a particular
question.
In 2002 I believe it was
"Guardian" was it that named,
that requested the best
hundred writers of the time
to select the best 100 books
in the history of humankind
and of course [inaudible]
"The Gilgamesh", "The Old Man
and the Sea", "The Iliad"
[inaudible] but when they got
to Don Quixote they couldn't
even categorize it as number one
and they named it the
best book ever written.
And then we see Don Quixote in every
day aspects; book marks, in statues,
in billboards, and everywhere.
Yet I was astonished that on April
23rd when we celebrate the death
of Cervantes, and Shakespeare,
Google Doodle did not pay tribute
to "Don Quixote" [laughter]
and Cervantes
and then it was a bombardment
of Shakespeare all the time.
I mean what's your take on that?
What's the, your take on
the fact that we have,
according to [inaudible],
according Carlos Fuentes,
according to [inaudible]
the best book ever written
that doesn't get the attention
that Shakespeare gets these days?
>> Hernan Pinillos: Thank you.
I don't know, I guess the
reasons to be political.
On literary grounds it's
difficult to defend.
There are Shakespearean
critics who caught
up in the what has been termed
bardolatry make pejorative
comparisons with Cervantes.
No it's quite common to say well,
in this regard Cervantes is better,
but only in this regard no?
You have [inaudible] who
termed "Don Quixote" a squire,
or could be a squire of "King Lear".
>> Wow.
>> Hernan Pinillos: Harold
Bloom talks about the invention
of the human based on Shakespeare
but there are many things
that Cervantes passed
on to literary tradition
that are not present in Shakespeare.
First of all, he invented
the prevalent form
of modern consciousness
which is the novel.
And Shakespeare's dealing with
the tragedy in the mode of cineca,
and Shakespeare read "Don Quixote"
part one no, [inaudible] lost play.
And he read a lot of
Spanish literature.
He read "La Philistina"
[assumed spelling].
He read sentimental romance
novels, pastoral novels
that influenced his writing a
lot, but Spain was the enemy
so it wasn't a matter
of quoting too much.
The ending of Hamlet you know with
those deaths, successive deaths,
accumulation of deaths,
that's present
in the Spanish sentimental
romance novel.
But yeah we don't have this crossing
of social lines in Shakespeare.
We don't have the strong feminine
characters, Dorotea, Marcela.
Now compare them with
Ophelia, Desdemona, you know?
You know all the women
who-- Cordelia--
you know, who let themselves
die for a man.
Women who were played
by male actors.
In Spain you had female
actors interpreting strong
women characters.
Another aspect which I didn't
develop, or I didn't touch is,
that is present in Cervantes' humor,
humor in all its levels
and functions.
You have slapstick comedy, but
you have the folly as a basis
to British humor, you
know, laughing at oneself.
In Cervantes' own creation of
his fig- [inaudible] figure
in the prologues, you
have [inaudible]
that doesn't take himself seriously.
And then you have also the first
time, according to one critic,
where the unmotivated action,
the rupture between cause
and effect is presented in
chapter 25 of the first part.
In Don Quixote's penance he's
going to do wild and crazy things
in imitation of Orlando who went
mad because of the infidelities
of Angelica with [inaudible].
But Sancho tells him
that you have no reason
and there's also Cardenio
who's going crazy
because Lucinda he
thinks has betrayed him.
And Don Quixote says
it's not a problem, no?
[Talking in foreign language]
I do this without a cause,
so he's just starts going
mad without a cause, no?
That's the first representation
of the absurd you have.
Think of Ionesco [assumed
spelling], Beckett,
or the great Spanish Theater of
the Absurd, unjustly forgotten,
Javier Consela Miramura
[assumed spelling].
Also Monty Python,
the Marx Brothers.
You have the essence, the core, the
germ of that humor in "Don Quixote".
>> First of all, thank
you very much.
That was very enlightening.
>> Hernan Pinillos: Thank you.
>> No philosophy has had more of
an impact on modern literature
and existentialism
[inaudible] mentioned Quixote
in that context [inaudible] Ortega.
Ortega said that man has no--
[ Inaudible ]
You've got Kafka, you've
got Dostoevsky,
all these writers heavily imbued
with existentialists [inaudible].
So we could call "Don
Quixote" rather
than [inaudible] the
first existentialist hero?
>> Hernan Pinillos:
Well, the thing is,
existentialism is a 20th
century movement, right?
With [inaudible].
So there are, I mean as a
historical determination,
we can do existentialist readings or
we could find existentialist motives
in "Hamlet" and in "Don Quixote"
but I think yeah that it,
in their core you can find
[inaudible] we see the construction
of the character Don Quixote
breaking away from the essence
of being an hidalgo, or
being a 50 year old bachelor,
and he just reinvents himself.
So that, yeah that strikes to
the, your quote, the separation
between history and nature.
And Ortega and Unamuno constructed
their philosophical systems
as commentaries on "Don Quixote".
In 1905, "Vida de Don
Quijote y Sancho",
life of Don Quixote and Sancho.
In 1914, "Meditations
on Don Quixote".
On just reflecting on "Don Quixote"
they came up with their system.
So you could say at least that they,
they're at the basis
of this thought school.
Thank you.
Yeah.
>> I was, I'm curious.
It doesn't have much to
do with your presentation
but I was just curious right now
since you brought up the question
of Shakespeare if you have read
the [talking in foreign language]
and what do you think about
this question of what is--
>> Hernan Pinillos:
I haven't read it.
>> Okay, forget it.
>> Hernan Pinillos: But
do you want to comment?
>> No, [inaudible] I wanted
to know what was your opinion
about [inaudible] the first novel
ever written or [inaudible].
>> Hernan Pinillos: Well the term
of novel you have the
idealized novels of--
I mean of Greek literature, the
Byzantine novels derived from Homer,
and then you have in Rome two
great novels in "Satyricon"
and "The Golden Ass"
[talking in foreign language]
so this is defining
the modern novel.
But also some critics
say the picaresque novel
"Lazarillo de Tormes"
is the first novel.
Some will say "La Philistina"
[assumed spelling] biological work,
play, that can be read
as a [inaudible] novel,
so there's a big theoretical
discussion but in terms
of modern literature with
this new heroic stance
with his proto-existentialist
elements,
characters that grow, that change.
Because Ancient Greek novels
were based on very fixed,
defined characteristics, no?
[Inaudible] the revelations, the
encounters, voyages, perfect loves.
But it's a different mode.
So this would be the mode
of the modern novel, okay?
Thanks.
>> Talia Guzman-Gonzales:
[Inaudible] questions?
Okay and then we're
going to [inaudible].
>> Hernan Pinillos: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.